es ist
zitter extrem
herzrase schweißusbrch
und Schwindel und bit
sprachstöriger spritzen masgrad und
Insulinpumpen als Diabetikerin weiß ich
der Alltag mit Diabetes Typ 1
iststrengend genau das passiert wenn ich
nicht
weißr genau
sind
jetzt muss ich spritz zum Teil so
anstrengend dass es bis zum Burnout
füren also ist
schrecklichste so formuliere wo
einfachabschluss richtig mat
SP Diabetes burnout ist überforderig im
Umgang mit der krankit und
SPI wieso ist das und ja
Konsequenz wenn man sich nmer um die
Diabetes kümmert sind fatal es verkürzt
ein Labe und richtet im Körper groß
schad warum also vernachlässiget
betroffen der
Diabetes in der Reportage erhoffe ich
mir ehrliche antworte n letzt auch von
mir
selber früh h Blutzuckerwert immer in B
das ist zwi ter und mir
Gott sous
h also da ob im Datum den
und den Blutzucker werd und das
wirklich Tag für
Tag ich und das den das B wie
immeren und krasse ist
d ich so nicht dass sie WS dass ich so
schlecht gestellt bin d Ich e mit dem
Diabetes nicht klar dass bei jeder
zweite Wert von da gefalscht ist also
die gute Wert nicht aufgeschie aber iche
natürlich viel viel schlechter die Wert
und ja da ich den einfach ersetzt g der
stell sorry Mami und Papi auf
die min Wert falschen damit sich andere
mich nicht Sorge macht das auch so
typisch Symptom v Diabetes Burnout also
e krass und ich muss das zeigen zum Teil
ich extra hö wer Z 11,2 oder da
17,2 einfach der
Glaubwürdigkeit schon GewSt me Elter
glauben mir nicht D min Wert so perfekt
und einfach zum Teil extra hö Wert dr
dam mit das glauwürdiger
über und sie
daadüber W ich jetzt zum ersten mal
offen und absolut ehrlich mit M Mami red
während
mir zmunter geschickt Primar ja SP ich
bin krankit länger im
Spital so viel
Besuch diabetes typ Diagnose verer lang
ich sie nicht akzeptiert Teenager mir
alles Z wde ich hab mich und me
Krankheit vernachlässigt hat Blutzucker
n gem hab Insulin gespritzt und meine
weren standig
hö und ich habe terogen WST du das
damals gemerkt dass irgendetwas mit mir
und mit me Diabetes nicht in ordn ist
also ich habe das so gefühlt so stark
gefühlt und immer wenn ich
mit dir reden wollte du hast mich immer
so
abgelehnt und
äh du hast immer so Ausreden gesucht und
manchmal war s auch so nervös wenn ich
dich gefragt habe also wie ist dein
zuckerzustand und ja und
so musste ich
halt selber die Kontrolle machen und
schauen also
äh was da los ist dann bin ich in der
Nacht aufgestanden habe dein
Messgerät geholt und deine also
Blutwerte angeschaut
und und war habe habe gemerkt dass ich
doch recht hatte also dass Du nicht klar
kommst und das schlimmste war auch für
mich weil du das weil du darüber nicht
sprechen
wolltest und das du das immer so für
Dich haben
wolltest
und ja ich habe das Gefühl gehabt dass
du
das dass du das alles auf sich nehmen
wolltest um mich zu schützen wie WST du
dals missverhalte
beschrieben wie so meine Burnout ges du
wie was hast du das gemerkt
also du warst irgendwie so leichtsinnig
du hast
mir das Gefühl gegeben dass du diese
Krankheit gar nicht so ernst nimmst und
auch heute wenn du beim Arzt ein Besuch
hast oder bei Diabetiker du sagst mir
auch nichts viel also du sagst ja nur
äh es war gut ja aber momentan ist es ja
gut ja aber für mir reicht es einfach
nicht wenn du mir das so
sagst
es ist gut ja das ganze Gespräch wo du
geführt hast das wird mich etwas mehr
beruhigen auch wenn wenn das nicht so
gut
ist ich muss einfach wirklich Wahrheit
wissen es ist recht speziell g für mich
z Mutter
wenn man das einfach nie gemacht h weiß
nicht ob das merkt aber
wie Gag Typ dafürie wo
[Musik]
über der mentale Zustand
redet me beide bis vorinand
versteckt zum nicht zeige wie es ein
Gott
ja ich bin nicht die einzig Diabetes
Burnout Diagnose J und blutzuerkrankit
immer noch nicht akzeptier sie ladet
mich zu me Familie ich bin Gespann wie
sie und ih ter mit dem Diabetes
umgt
Hall Zar verzählt mir im Vorgespräch
dass sie oft hö Blutzucker WT of sch
dasas und nerve das K die zum Verlust
vom augicht oder z versage
führ blutzuer
BL im schlimmst Fall m F amputiert wer
aus Herzinfarkt und schlagfall Risiko
stiegt mit hö
Blutzuckerwert ein G Wert liegt ungefähr
zwischen 5 und
h
genauus dem Grund dass ke
Insulin respektiv Z wenig wie H jetzt
gespürt ichpür immer dass ich mega viel
Durst hab z so Rivella oder so trinke
ich normalerwes nie aber wenn ich h
immer Lust auf Rivella und muss
mE das sind so zwei
hauptzeiche
genau sind erschrocken so ein Wert von
29,3 od das so kann zum Glück nicht
sehen
ja ja macht man sich
Sorge ja hin und wieder kom da muss man
einfach sagen
okay ich hab mich best gemacht W ich hab
und jetzt ist
so so h
B du das gich ja schonfang immer saelber
Insulin bestellt
immerber der SCH
immerber bestellen also es ist
schcklich so formuliere wo einfach W V
Orang trinken und das ich vor dem Spital
no und es sind so viel Faktor wo man
nicht unterchätz
wo anders ich
mitol mit pr mit
diabetolog und dann ja
z
vlig mit M
oder
diabetologverständlichigt und sie reü
was aufgab ich sehr
natürlich Termin das
mirh im auch we tut nein es ist einfach
so schön dass ich so wundervolle Elter
habe und mich auch so n wenn ich bin und
ich du mich selber schon genug
verurteile und S ist so schön dass sie
einfach ja einfach für mich da sind und
nicht auch no meh
verurteilet und es ist es ist für mich
nicht einfach es ist
wirklich ja
Challenge und zwar jeden Tag man ich
einfacher man ich schlechter
aber
ja diabetesdiagnose h Zara in Krise
gestürzt jetzt sogar Suizid
Gedanke W
ich ich war n da we wirklich ich schon
paar mal den de Balkon
gumüber
es tut einach gut
mal auch fühlt ja od h du
andere
also
bin
Familie und ja
jetzt
ja CIA Ciao es git ein sa wo Zara und
ich e extrem unterscheidet und
zwar Kommunikation mit der Familie über
Diabetes also sie hat da recht offen mit
ihren älter und das gesch die drede und
macht auch gern und sie sind zwar ein
emotionale Unterstützig aber schlich
muss SAR
jariff
und Wert g V fast 30 ich muss sagen da
bin ich kurz schon sehr
schockier ich bin mit zum WT sogar t
Wert ist spitalert
worden und also für mich ist komisch g
dass die andere nicht so
schockiertind aber irgendwie ist das
jetzt nicht so dramatisiert wurde wie
z.B mir dahi W also be mir W wirklich so
was D zu h vergessen Spritze h anders
Gass komisch g ist das Insulin viicht n
mE gut und ist das so
ja ich hab dankt wenn sch passiert
nmlich mit
zum im allergröchte hausm dasabetiker
es
ist am morgenn ze Handy
am Schweiß geb
aufacht Bett
wirklich
und für Zucker alle Diabetiker wür
wahrscheinlich sagen bist du dumm was
nimmst du dich
auf bevor du stirbst so fühlt sich das
der Kamera merkt aber es ist
zitter extrem herzrase schweißusbr
und Schwindel und bit
sprchstörigear kein hungerar kein Bo
zum find
nicht aber
muss
und schlim
eig mus
[Applaus]
mus
Chips vor 12 Jahr hab ich im Kind
spitalzern
diabetesdiagnose
Zimmer
vin
gehört 27 zum Glück gehtag Social Media
ich erfah Dur und her schie dass
Diabetes
Burnout wie ist mit dir nachangen so die
erste Z Jahr nach der Diagnose ich bin
Schul gegangen und hat
den jah später genau
ich k ab praktisch nicht gessen und hat
so die Notlüge ich
schessessen ichessen und me lang gar
nicht so und was ist denn das hinter
gleich nicht Spritze das macht sie kurz
vor Mittag vermutet Lisa dass ihr Zucker
t ist darum holen wir jetzt sch bis zum
Essen mer man nicht dass man unter
Zucker das im schlimmst
fallödlich
also l
genau
langsam geh jetzt
Kaffe Schwangere mit Diabetes m übrigens
blutzuerwert besonders
gut kan zu Komplikationen be der Geburt
oder zu fallbildig beim
Kind mega schwierig das Schätze wie sch
ist und es st
nichtu nervt das das ist z ke genau Gram
oder schon Brot unterschiedlich sch od
so
Glasse Glasse Sprit
immer süßes aber
eigentlich meistens gar nicht so viel
Zucker also einfach so
hassen ich mit 50 g rechnen es wird
wahrscheinlich nicht le ich mag auch
nicht ganze
genau jetzt automatisch das ist mit
insulinbom verbunden und das got jetzt
über das schluch W da hinterin ist
automatisch
mehr Diabetiker und Diabetikerinnen m
ganz genau wissen Kohlenhydrat mal Hand
den ausre viel Einheit Insulin brauch
mich nervt wenn nwer aufgelichtet sind
also schätze ich jetzt auch für das
Sandwich
se 12 Jahr Sprit ich mir F bis mal am
Tag Insulin schon länger SPI mit dem
Gedanke mir au Pumpe zu Lisa das müsame
Proz V
für mich ein V der grü warum ich
Diabetes
Burnout der Lisa große Rolle
gespieltst du auch sagen dass
du dass
du
diabet ohne das
jetzt noch
akzeptiert ins geheim kann man schon
sagen
diabetesout wenn ich weniger bra weniger
Insulin und ich muss weniger Spritze
machen ang
Kontrolltermine das ist in der Fall
wieder
m
terminber
ja und irgend we mus und e Luft gar
nicht und ja und ich bin wir
hospitalisiert
geshen glaub ich ich hat schabschluss
nicht richtig gemacht ich Spital nachdem
du das realisiert h dass du jetzt dich
andere
mus akzeptiert oder doch noch längerucht
ich glaub es doch noch längerucht ich
hab ich z und me Diabetes
akepti die Akzeptanz V der Krankheit und
das Gefühl von körperlicher und
emotionaler erschöpfig aufgrund von
derorderige W mit Diabetes mit sich
bringt ich merke Symptom sind wend dem
Diabetes
Burnout krass was sie alles gemacht zum
wirklich Diabetes ignorierere dass sie
einfach aufört sie gehofft dass das so
wegt ja auch wieder mal eine neue Art V
Diabetes
Burnout so und es schient als ob ich
mich verchn hab beim Sandwich und genau
das passiert wenn ich nicht
weißydrat genau sind dann der Wert
14,1 mit der tendanz
stiegend und das bedeutet dass ich nicht
los fahreen Autofahren mit hö
Wert jetzt muss ich spritz und den
losfahren und bis das Insulin wirkt dur
15 Minuten ja wenn wir mal im Stress ist
oder irendwi SP ist das halt blöd kan
einfach losfahren musst du Mass
spit
warte ich treff mich wieder mit der Sara
sie mich wig zum
Mittag ich m n me über das Diabetes
Burnout erfahren ich stell schwer und
einsam vor allezw wenn man sich Diabetes
Burnout
befindet vor
mir Diabetikerin wie immer
blutzuckerm
zuckermass von
skal bis 12
okay ja hö
genau wie vi bist morgen se okay
Morgen und jetzt und was meinst
sich will ich
vor okay ohne Spritze nein ichepritzt
aber ja okay
ja jetzt so WN wir das normal machen
oder wirst du das jetzt normal auch
machen wenn ich Lust
hab ich Portion und wie viel Insulin ich
Spritzen
mus bei mir auch schätzig Sa 2 g
kohlhydrat das
heißt
2,4 wenig
ja so s gespritzt sinheit oder so
ja vier Z
einheitch
Gefühl hchen
blutass
6,6 ja gut
ja also ich ma jetzt mal
F
ja
ne das ist so das Ding wo am Meister
Diabetes komisch aber nicht
normal also alles
ja sorry alles du kannst nicht einfach
andere Marathon springen oder so oder du
bist so ich muss planen dass er geh ich
muss Plan dass
ich ich muss Plan
dass Material
funktioniert aber alles
und
beschriebenabet einfach so ke Bock duf n
auf Masse n me berechnen me W so
ignorierere je meh
ignoriert W ich
sagen und das ist so
verzwickreis
we be mir so ess selbst spild undter
Wert und das alles so miteinand kurb ja
so wieder schlechte Werke und dann bin
ich so jetzt ist wieder emotional ja
mich frustriert und so ist nur noch
schlimmer dann finde ich mich selber
wieder mehr scheiße ich mich no meh
verurteil so wow wo da jetzt das auf
oder voll genau wo
F andere
richtig mer ja danke
dir L mit Diabetes Typ 1 rund um
Blutzucker im sogenann zielber Hal
schafft man das n erhöt sich Risiko ver
folgchade moderne Technik wie
Insulinpumpen und blutzuersensore H der
Umgang mit den Gerät ist aber für
Betroffene oft sehr herausfordernd und
führt zu psychischeer Problem und jetzt
wir genau und WT sch einige Löcher vor
dem zü also gibt gich blaumesser so ja
Hal Stelle Stelle jetzt gerade nicht W
da aber es gibt man wo es einfach
wirklich schmerzt und dann so Spiegel
und B
so wieso ist das und ja und im Alltag
fest das
betrchtige ich bin nicht free Körper
oder es fühlt sich nicht free an es ist
halt
einfachis wo einfach
immer ichpüre verzwi V der Sar sie
erklärt mir dass sie irgendwann ihre
Diabetes wegbringen wird und dasem sie
ihres bewusst sie und ihre Gefühl
kontrolliert das heißt jetzt also wenn
ich aufhöre hier immer die ganze die
Angst die so schwingen und wieder
schaffe zurück da dann irgende krank gar
nicht manifestiere will ich andere
Gefühl hab und das ist so
also also WST du wie
sagen das chronische Krankheit heile ja
da
git ganze Ding so mit Erkenntnis und und
zügs
und Kopie und
Handanalyse alles min
forschigsarbeit der Glaube selbstheilig
vom Diabetes für mich es erstzeiche von
me Diabetes
Burnout zum dem ganze für paar wenige
Stunde Z F SAR fast jede Tag zu r
daser P die Pumpe und es istes Kind es
immer irg Biss schreit was heißt also
das
Alarm mus wieder aktivieren ich
vergessen oder und dann oder Batterie le
oder ampul le oder einfach
so V mir das aber nicht nein es jetzt
nur vibriert
aber
jaes der
mich Himmel katapultiert
so
ruhig und sichelber besser im Stall
komisch Diabetes Diabetes immer so erste
Bild die dick Frau Zucker ist da ich
nicht so die perfekte Modelfigur oder so
hab immer so scannerblck so wenn ich
sage ja Diabetes oder und dann ist auch
für mich meel mit Scham verknüpft zum
drüber sag hey kan Diabetes ich nutz
anderes Wort an
Diabetes
ich
Unterfunktion eiskabel
weniger schr
Schritt danke danke dir G
C also es sind jetzt paar Stunden
vergangen und ich noch sch Blutzucker
zum l ob ich richtig geschätzter
nicht also
wie prophezeit ist mE
Blutzucker zum glü kan
ich und bevor ich los warte bis Zucker
h mit tiefen Blutzucker darf man nicht
fahren
es beschaftigt mich dass Zara ihre krank
kann akzeptieren und sie sogar
selbsthilig V Diabetes glaubt ich ben
sehr skeptisch und meine
treffpreche ich sie z diabeteskontrolle
Begleit hab heilig wenn F
sind andere
fak Arbeit einfach über dasus gewachsen
bin oder ja anders gesehen und ich weiß
als es anders möglich
ist reagiert andere auf das Al jetzt z.B
den Arzt
nachher 20 Jahr sie schon diabetolog und
das noch sie sie den wieder zu
Vernunft schon probiert aber
ja und da weiß ich halt einfach ich hab
Biss
und das ist Thema W ich einfach nicht
los für mich ist ja wie so mega
schwierig zum vorstellen also kann man
das für mich geht so ke alternativ also
jetzt noch nicht ke Alternative zu
Insulin und Gerät wei
darum wie
ich zum diabetolog er untersucht wie hö
ih blutzuckerwer in der Lette bis
ichtlich was der
wer letzte Woche Diabetes und Arzt Z
Wochen Wert
geschickt
ja
ja wie ist es gang
B
Z
ja geseh man ist
besser schlechter aber ich hab
Motivation immer hin
längerte
Finger die
Tropf gen im Durchschnittswert seit
hbasc ein guute Wert liegt ungefähr
zwischen 5 und
7,5,5 let
mal,3 weiß gar nicht mus was
2,7 okay
0,2 okay
also ja
ja was denken sie sch let mal die letzte
paar mal so drüber Gert aber m Ziel ist
ja nicht dass ich immer hö aber es
braucht einfach mega viel
L
10,5 es ist ja besser als letzt mal
g ja es ist schon besser aber es ist sch
nicht
gut nicht so WN ich
[Musik]
will Stress wenn man den wieder geh
stiegt wieder und sinkt die ganze Zeit
immer kontrolliert werden gern
also das Thema ja in Reportage das
Diabetes Burnout würd sie sagen s
befindet sich in es gibt durchus
paar Faktoren od paar Begebenheit wo man
durchus sag das fr Baumann sicherzeich V
Diabetes Burnout da sind und ich kann
jetzt frumann paar Jahr und Verlauf wie
Amfang und und wie jetzt ist und da hat
sich halt sch der letzte letzte Jahr
sicher das Ganze nach
M verschärft und ich glaube die Symptom
e sich
nmer groß um die Diabetes kümmer was
sich dann halt e aus wirkt dass man
n Massen oder Diabetes ganz wi hinen ist
m eben ein ermüdiges Abrennen von der
krankit ich denke das hab wir B gut Kön
gesehen
du was FT noch dass
du oder
de ja einfach Motivation und dass man
sich selber gern h dass man das für sich
macht es g nur das mir dass ich mE wert
bin dass ich gut zu mir l bla Blabla
will ja brauch mega
viel ich GL das isto wichtig ist
Motivation ist wichtig aber die Kranken
könen akzeptiere zum Stück wie dass es
halt zu einem gehört und dass mit die
Kranken vor allem das Le lang hat das W
natürich toll W man könte sagen jah sind
wir SMer so wie vom medizinische her
dass die Kranke kalt ist und das ist das
wir
ja der Arzt g nicht dass Diabetes in
absehbarer Teiler da sind sich die beide
uneinig irgendein wde ich das let mal
ich WD so juble
s gute morgen ich dankt ich w
zeigen das
das die letzte malahzeit
wird wo
ich mit
Insulin abdecken bzw mit der
Spritze weil nacher got ist
Kantonsspital Zug
und wird zum ersten Mal Miren Pumpe
gesetzt
und ich weiß D ich mich jahrelang davor
drückte also ein Symptom W Diabetes mir
definitiv
blobben ab neue technische
Gerät glaube dass ich die noch
BRE und
deshalb das
dumm
hallo hallo guten Morgen so jetzt ist
der große Moment da jetzt würden wir
Pump
starten
super ja Infusionsstelle vorbereiten al
der Ort glaub für mich für der Anfang
mal
gut so den
platziieren so
prima
dening
drücken unden ist es
prima
so so ich ne euch mit
zu der Malzeit mit der
Pumpe und ich habeade vor Kohlenhydrat
ausgerechnet alles
abgewet sind
ungefähr 30 g
kohlhydrat
jetzt neue
grätli das einfach
der zum mal
3,46 Einheiten
bestätigen
Start ich ver mich gerade wieso ich das
jetzt fr gemacht
habe wieso es ist so einfach aber
vielleicht n früher zum das ze ich bis
erst gerade am Test der erste Tag die
erste
Malzeit es ist jetzt ein mon die Pomp
trage und es jetzt schon so
viel bin immer noch mefed mit der
Entscheidig mir ist extrem wichtig
Reportage auf zeigigen das Diabetes Typ
1 Wo eere Gesellschaft of das halb so
wild oder unsichtbar gilt so überfordern
Sie dass es z Burnout die zuckerkrank
wirklich ernst und ich hoffe dass ich
das da K ze vor allem W nicht wirklich
viel über Diabetes WS und für alle
Diabetiker und diabetikerinen da BR das
Tabu und redet drüber wenn Mö undmer
Burnout sind suchet euch hilf das ist
das was wirklich Stärke zeigt kannst du
wo auch mit dem Diabetes h oder sogar
das Diabetes Burnout h dann verz doch mE
Kommentar und wenn Frage zu beantworte
ich sie dir gern im q& wo folgt wenn dir
fol gefallen hätten geradekanal
abonnieren und mehr Folge geht's jetzt
da